you've likely noticed gas prices are
surging because of the economic fallout
from the russian invasion of ukraine the
u.s average per gallon topped four
dollars for the first time in more than
a decade and many experts want prices
will rise even further and not just for
gas but also for other essential goods
carter evans is at a gas station in los
angeles carter what are the prices
looking like over there this morning
well take a look behind me you can see
the price is so high here in the sevens
rising so quickly looks like they ran
out of sixes there for the top price
there states like new jersey and
pennsylvania will they also hit all-time
highs and prices could keep rising if
the white house makes good on its threat
to ban all russian oil
imports i have a baby so i gotta gotta
say where i can
drivers spent the weekend in long lines
for cheaper gas in southern california
where prices average more than five
dollars a gallon i had to get here early
for gas because it's this crazy out
there it's over six dollars nationally
gas prices are skyrocketing averaging
more than four dollars a gallon a
typical driver is paying 16 dollars more
to fill up than this time last year
russia's invasion of ukraine putting
pressure on global oil markets is partly
to blame when can we see gas prices
actually start to decline
realistically it's going to be a you
know rougher the next six months ucla
senior economist leo feller says the war
in ukraine is impacting its exports and
russia's we're seeing big supply shocks
right we're seeing oil prices go up
we're seeing wheat prices go up ukraine
is the bread basket of europe right so
there is a lot of concern that this is
going to make a inflationary problem
even worse
russia and ukraine supplied nearly a
third of the world's wheat last year and
since the invasion exports have come to
a standstill meaning shoppers could see
a rise in prices for items like cereal
and bread and even meat since some
farmers rely on wheat to feed livestock
how long is this going to last it's
going to last as long as a war between
russia and ukraine lasts and until we
are able to ramp up production in the
u.s
the demand is there
now by the end of the week we could see
the national average price of gas
shattered the all-time high record of 4
11 a gallon but with oil close to 100
bucks a barrel well u.s oil producers
will probably ramp up production but you
see that takes time about six months to
get into the pipeline nate
from the pump to the grocery store maybe
even more carter thank you